>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[ Applause ]
>> Karen Gardner: Hi everyone.
I am Karen Gardner.
I'm a Senior Executive
Director for Reading Partners.
I actually am the Executive
Director for Washington DC,
but I'm here representing
my colleagues
across the country today.
And it's such a pleasure to be
with the Library of Congress
in the Center for the Book.
It's such an honor to be
recognized in this way
and to have the opportunity
to collaborate
with all of you today.
So as I get started, I'd like
for you to just take a moment
and think about how different
your life would be today
if you had not learned
how to read proficiently.
Think about the opportunities
that you have been afforded,
your academic success,
your career achievements,
the ability to know how
and where to get resources
for yourself and for your family
when you've really needed it.
The literacy crisis in the
United States for our children
and for adults is
truly an epidemic.
We know that 20% of students,
fourth grade students
from low income homes
are currently reading
at grade level, only 20%.
That's one out of five.
And we also know that students
who are not on grade level
by the fourth grade are four
times less likely to graduate
from high school on time.
So that's why I'm proud
to be at Reading Partners
where we are leveraging
communities across the country
to make sure that our
students are matched
with a cure for this epidemic.
We work with 14 cities
across the United States.
And this past year we
served over 11,000 students
with its individualized
proven model.
So how does it work?
First of all, we
partner with schools,
so we are an in-school program.
We have a reading center
in each of our schools
where we provide pullout
instruction, one-on-one,
utilizing community
volunteers as well
as a nationwide partnership
with AmeriCorps,
similar to the Minnesota
Reading Corps.
Second, we leverage
community volunteers,
as I mentioned before,
and this allows us
to multiply the resources that
we provide to the community.
And third, our program
is individualized
on meeting each student exactly
where they need to be served
in order to develop
their literacy skills.
And as a result, 83% of our
students this past year met
or exceeded their end of
year literacy growth goals.
So we know that our
program truly works.
And this has been proven
by three different
independent studies
that have been done
on Reading Partners.
The first was concluded
in 2014 by MDRC.
It was a gold standard
research study,
randomized control
trial study and showed
that Reading Partners
has a positive
and statistically
significant impact
on improving reading
proficiency.
And similar to this, APA,
not the APA where most
of us are familiar with
it but Augenblick, Palaich
and Associates has conducted a
study that's been multiple years
in Colorado, as we've
launched our program there,
that has also shown this
positive impact on students
who receive Reading
Partners in comparison
to a comparison group.
And this has been
particularly true
for English language learners.
And the third study that we
are in the midst of right now
through Child Trends in
the state of California,
we are in year one
of two, excuse me.
We just concluded year one
of two and found, again,
the same trend of improving
reading proficiency for students
that are receiving our program
in the state of California.
But what I'm particularly
excited about with this study is
that it's also showing
really positive results
in social-emotional learning,
which we believed was is
to be true given the fact that
we're connecting caring adults
with students, providing
that relationship.
However, now this
study is showing that.
It's just really
exciting to see.
Thank you so much.
And please let me know if
you have any questions.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.